some have called it the mother of all
battles and some argue that its
television coverage changed the face of
war it's hard to get everyone to agree
when it comes to the first gulf war the
media attention for saddam hussein dates
back to august 2 1990 when the race
ordered his troops to invade the
neighboring kuwait a small emmy rate of
only 18 000 square kilometers with 4.5
million inhabitants largely living in
the capital al-kuwait but very rich in
oil fields war broke out on the night of
january 1617 1991 after a series of
ultimatums from the united nations
asking for the withdrawal of iraqi
forces from kuwait however a conflict
that didn't last long six weeks just
long enough for a coalition of 34
countries led by the united states to
showcase its overwhelming superiority by
deploying over 500 000 troops and
forcing the iraqi leader to surrender
the following february 28th it was an
intense few weeks however and the
relentless news coverage ended up making
the first glue for a real media event in
particular it was always in the
spotlight of cnn an old news channel
established just over 10 years earlier
which imposed itself from the eyes of
the world by providing continuous news
coverage of the progress of operation
desert storm the actual military action
against iraq preceded by desert shield
or the massive deployment of troops to
saudi arabia to contain iraqi ambitions
television coverage that influenced us
foreign policy decisions to the point of
affecting the course of the conflict
according to what has been called the
cnn effect then we come back to it
before the fateful day of the invasion
no one had been more concerned about the
iraqi leader even though he had been
leading the baath regime from the
secular socialist inspired bath party
since 1979 no one in the context of
numerous meetings among top politicians
in the arab region held on the eve of
the invasion guessed or wanted to guess
that iraq would prove to be an important
player on the international stage and
that its dictator's policies would pose
a threat to the world order certainly
the crisis triggered by the invasion of
kuwait can be regarded not only as one
of the major international crises of the
post-war period but also as a unique
event indeed it's the first major post
called war crisis to be located outside
the dimension of east west confrontation
for the first time a member of the
united nations kuwait precisely hadn't
just been invaded but totally occupied
and annexed by another causing hundreds
of thousands of displaced people
disruption of trade of two major oil
producers and worldwide economic
uncertainty if we analyze the scale of
this war in terms of casualties we find
that it's far less than that of the
major wars after 1945 think of korea
with 4.3 million dead vietnam with over
2 million the iran-iraq war with over
600 000 or lebanon with 250 000 but from
the point of view of mobilization and
armaments used this was after korea the
largest interstate conflict since world
war ii militarily we can identify three
distinctive features of it the first is
the extreme asymmetry of casualties
facilitated by the rise of new
technologies tens of thousands of
casualties on the iraqi side a few
hundred on the coalition side the second
is the particular way the conflict ended
with a sudden call for a halt by george
bush senior at a time when he could have
annihilated saddam altogether the third
and maybe most dramatic is the
ecological disaster that came with it
following the iraqi decision to set fire
to kuwait's oil fields during the
retreat you remember the famous scene
from the movie jarhead don't you
it's raining
it's running
of course it wasn't the first time that
war and ecological destruction went
hand-in-hand but in this case the
destructive action found on military
justification and was devastating to the
healthiness of the air over a large area
of west asia but exactly when did the
hostilities date back to the fateful
august 2 1990 is only the culmination of
a process rooted in september 1980 when
war operations between iraq and iran
began resulting in a conflict that cost
more than half a million dead and ended
with neither winners nor losers but a
ceasefire requested by tehran on august
8 1988. of this conflict the american
public but not the government and secret
services of course knew almost nothing
just as it was barely aware of the
geopolitical rise of saddam hussein's
iraq a military power to be exact the
fourth largest in the world by number of
armed forces after the ussr china and
the united states 55 divisions 1 million
trained men 500 000 aircrafts and 5 500
tanks but it was a power with disastrous
public finances with an accumulated debt
to 100 billion dollars in 1988 due to
the government's huge military expenses
during the eight years of bloody war a
debt that couldn't be repaired even by
attempting to promote the private sector
and domestic agriculture but saddam was
convinced that the economy would recover
believing he could count on the support
of oil lords kuwait saudi arabia and the
united arab emirates in fact the three
countries along with the united states
and israel had supported in various
forms the iraq iran war of the late
1980s to contain shiite fundamentalism
provoked by the komeini revolution and
saddam expected them to honor their
depth of gratitude for benefiting from
iraq's protective shield against the
iranian threat in response there was a
rush to drain the oil fields and the
release of large quantities of oil onto
the market causing its price to plummet
from 18 to 13 dollars a barrel but the
initiative taken by kuwait was the
stroke that broke the camel's back you
should know that since the 1930s iraq
had repeatedly claimed the sovereignty
over kuwait on some occasions denying
its legitimacy as a separate state on
others questioning the boundary the
limitation between the two countries
because the way the united kingdom had
drawn its border back in 1923 prevented
iraq from controlling a proper outlet to
the persian gulf corresponding to the
disputed bubiyan and warba islands and
the piece of desert where the rumayala
deposit is located crossing the border
between the two states and always
claimed by iraq we said in the aftermath
of the ceasefire demanded by tehran
kuwait contravening the extraction quota
agreements established at opec
organization of the petroleum exporting
countries increased crude oil extraction
from the rumyla fields this episode
known as oil theft through slant
drilling which is a particular
extraction technique using non-vertical
drills brought more than 2.4 billion
dollars into the country's treasury
corresponding to about 300 000 barrels
of oil per day an action that collapsed
baghdad's revenue which was ninety
percent dependent on crude oil by about
seven billion dollars a year while
interest on the debt also amounted to
seven billion dollars in fact none of
the gulf countries came to saddam zaid
by proposing to negotiate the less
honorable forms of debt repayment
despite the rise constant requests to
ease the pressure so the invasion of
kuwait would offer a multi-layered
solution a distraction from domestic
discontent over economic mismanagement
the possibility of acquiring kuwait
assets and investments and the seizure
of the oil fields themselves which was
equivalent to controlling about one
fifth of all world oil saddam's
hostility found confirmation on an
important occasion at the arab league
meeting held on july 16 1990 iraqi
foreign minister tarek aziz delivered to
the league's secretary-general chadley
libby a memorandum in the shape of a
declaration of war accusing kuwait of
stealing oil and the remaining gulf
countries of plotting an economic
conspiracy against iraq aimed at putting
it out of business once and for all we
can say that the iraqi dictator already
supported in the past by the west was
convinced that his move would have no
practical consequences apart from the
usual ritual protests this is confirmed
by the july 25 1990 summons of u.s
ambassador epper glaspie saddam gave her
barely an hour's notice glaspy didn't
make it in time to ask the state
department for instructions and the
dialogue between the two resolved into
comedy of misunderstandings too absorbed
in the problems of the east the diplomat
implied that the us didn't want to
intrude on inter-arab disputes the iraqi
dictator convinced that it had made
these intentions clear believed he had
obtained the tacit u.s green light to
invade kuwait an enormous mistake that
would cost iraq dearly which from the
time of the coalition ground attack
dated february 24 1991 lost control of
kuwait in just four days very
controversial where the u.s airstrikes
on the night of february 26 27 directed
against iraqi forces retreating from
kuwait to the city of basra the allies
initially bumped the head and tail of
the huge column of vehicles traveling on
the so-called highway of death so as to
block the convoy and make it a static
target for subsequent attacks some
commentators suggested that the use of
force had been disproportionate since
the iraqis had agreed to withdraw in
compliance with u.n resolution 660 and
the convoy included kuwaiti prisoners
politicians and palestinian civilian
refugees in any case saddam remained in
power cracking down hard on kurdish
uprisings in the north and shiite
uprisings in the south but had to accept
the u.n resolution 687
pledging to destroy his arsenals of
unconventional weapons pay reparation
for war damage and divide by two
security zones created by the coalition
for kurds and shiites precisely the
allied victory though described by
almost all the western press as
challenging but fair with saddam hussein
compared to adolf hitler and his
fearsome army to the wermacht was easy
and with very few casualties the whole
thing as we shall see was peppered with
the campaign of mystification in the
western press to justify the military
intervention and the spectacular life
broadcast by journalist peter arnett
from baghdad's rashid hotel describing
the bombing for hours it was the first
time it happened on live television and
many including the italian historian
antonio scurati say that this
contributed to the viewers lack of
empathy for the war who from then on
became accustomed to seeing death and
bombs on the screen not as a chilling
loss of life but as an effective
destruction against the boredom the
allied victory was easy but bush was
unable or maybe unwilling to take
advantage of the internal tensions in
iraqi society to deal a decisive blow to
saddam it was felt that attained but not
ideologically fundamentalist enemy could
still come in handy later against
possible unrest caused by peoples
bordering the iraqis apparently friendly
but actually hostile we mustn't forget
then that a large section of islamic
public opinion spoke out in favor of
saddam himself seeing the coalition's
presence as unwelcome western
interference in middle eastern affairs
and damage to the holy sites of islam
saddam after having always been utterly
secular and completely indifferent to
religion knew how to sniff the wind of
protest and began to pose as a protector
of islam attending public prayers waving
the rhetoric of faith his regime
survived but internal rivalries kurdish
independence shiite discontent were
never quelled and came back to the
surface during the second gulf war
that's another story now is the time to
talk about cnn effect but before we get
there let's see how american and it's
allies intervention in a conflict that
was taking place on the other side of
the world was justified the bush
administration tried to convince world
opinion that a real threat was imminent
and the saudis that an american presence
in the gulf was inevitable on august 15
1990 it was george bush senior himself
who advanced the first rational
explanation our jobs our way of life our
freedom and that of friendly countries
around the world would suffer if control
of the world's great oil reserves fell
into the hands of that one man saddam
hussein reasons that seemed far-fetched
there was no real threat to freedom
except as historian theodore draper put
it to that freedom to drive your car on
cheap fuel but interests in the gulf
area didn't stop at oil take for example
the massive chemical arsenal in the
hands of saddam hussein historical
reconstructions show how western aid was
instrumental in the development of the
iraqi weapons program mentioning more
than 2 000 companies involved in various
ways in the formation of the iraqi war
industry washington has long denied
possessing information regarding the
chemical arsenal in the hands of the
race but recent studies prove otherwise
on august 23 2013 foreign policy
published a survey showing top secret
documents in hand that the u.s was aware
of the existence of these weapons as
early as 1984 and was constantly
monitoring saddam hussein's plans for a
chemical attack on iran which would have
banned tehran in 1988 through the use of
sarin gas and mustard gas the cia had
information that for decades remained in
the secret archives and about which the
government was always silent even
strongly condemning the use of these
instruments of war which moreover was
prohibited by the geneva protocol of
1925 ratified by the united states in
1975. prior to that survey it was known
that the us had provided iraq with
intelligence support and that there was
only suspicion that the chemical arsenal
was being used in retaliation for war
more than suspicions awareness in fact
some declassified documents extracted
from the national archives in college
park maryland show how senor us
officials had been briefed about the
extent of the nerve gas attacks as
journalist shane harris argued this
amounted to a tacit u.s admission of
complicity in one of the most gruesome
chemical weapons attacks ever launched
in open contrast to the geneva protocol
already mentioned and what about
diplomatic relations between the united
states and iraq well they were put at
risk even before the outbreak of the war
on february 15 1990 voice of america the
official radio and television service of
the us government broadcast a program
appealing to the public for a general
mobilization against authoritarian
regimes around the world iraq was
mentioned almost constantly and saddam
was portrayed as one of the worst
expressions of tyranny an apology came
immediately from washington but the
matter was never digested by the iraqi
leader an apology that glaspy also made
to him remember the american diplomat
for how he had been portrayed in the
interview conducted by diane sawyer on
abc news claiming that that was the
typical journalistic method used to
discredit any political figure but how
far did the news media go the news
outlets succeeded in legitimizing the us
military intervention in the gulf
overnight transforming saddam hussein
from a friend of the west to the
embodiment of adolf hitler endorsing
george bush senior's line of thinking
think that the new york times in an
editorial published on august 9 1990
stated that president bush has drawn a
line in the sand committing u.s forces
to face down saddam hussein the costs
and risks are enormous but on balance he
has made the right choice in the right
way saddam had officially become a u.s
problem and the proof lies in the fact
that in the time span between august 2
and november 8 1990 the washington post
and the new york times began to cover
iraq saudi arabia and kuwait constantly
the former published a total of over
1700 articles on the subject and the
latter over 2400 with a focus on news
events obviously ignoring the real
reasons for the conflict and why u.s
iraq relations had worsened in recent
years in short an apt comparison that
resonated with the people accepted by 6
out of 10 americans as reported in a
poll conducted between august 9 and 10
1990 for the new york times for the
television industry on the other hand
the gulf war was more of a story of
american prowess especially a
celebration of technological power it's
estimated that 17 of the images shown
were shots of missiles and cutting-edge
war technology consider that on january
22 1991 cnn spoke of the patriot
missiles as if they were human actors
but it was also a glorification of the
courage determination and skill of
american soldiers if with vietnam
television had brought to light the
atrocities of war something different
was happening with the gulf a narrative
marked by the opposition between good
and evil was adopted packaged within a
real show complete with custom logo and
music to accompany the rappers a show
expertly hosted by cnn the green light
for operation desert storm came when new
york was minutes away from 7 pm on
january 16 1991 the news network's prime
time on the first night of non-stop
bombing americans were addicted to the
images of war and didn't tear themselves
away from the live broadcasts on cnn
this was because shortly after the
attack on baghdad began all the networks
lost their video link from iraq the only
broadcaster to maintain it with its
reporters was precisely cnn on the
screens were the images of three
journalists work correspondent peter
arnett reporter john holliman and tv
anchorman bernard show in fact the cnn
in september 1990 had managed to obtain
permission from iraqi officials to
install a four-wire satellite phone a
device that could withstand signal loss
on january 17 all crews present in
baghdad including cnns were asked to
leave the rashid hotel headquarters of
the international press marked as a
coalition bombing target for the
following night holy man and show
decided to leave while peter arnett
remained on site the rashida hotel was
never bombed and for the next two weeks
arnett was the only us citizen
broadcasting information and interviews
from iraq via the four wire link carried
on a truck with the large cnn initials
advisable on the canopy so that
coalition planes wouldn't mistake the
vehicle for a scooted missile shipment
so by the end of the month cnn became
the only news provider for more than 100
countries the primary source of
information from the gulf to ensure that
cnn as an all news channel could
broadcast 24 7 news two military
analysts were hired on a permanent basis
former air force major general perry
mccoy smith and military strategy expert
james blackwell it was major mccoy smith
in one of his books who explained the
formula for the american broadcaster's
success cnn had the reporters the
satellite link-ups the engineers the
producers and expert commentators in
place or on standby he had a leadership
team which understood before the war
broke out that this was going to be a
story of giant proportions the job of
the analysts was to always be at the
broadcaster's back and call always ready
to comment on the images to explain the
strategic meaning of a certain bombing
and the technical details about recon
planes and missiles dropped on a variety
of targets a rather simple example
explains the power of the media in
influencing public opinion on january 23
1991 barely a week into the war major
smith during a broadcaster recommended
reading three books to better understand
the strategies behind ongoing operations
all three sold out by the same evening
and publishers rushed with reprinting
one of the three titles boomed in demand
and forced the publishers to reprint 600
000 copies however the power of cnn
effect also affected foreign policy
decisions a case study is from february
1991 and is related to kurdish refugees
who had sowed to shelter from iraqi
forces in the mountains southeast of
turkey media coverage of the kurdish
crisis was intensive emphasizing both
the precarious conditions in which the
kurds were living and they demand that
something be done to help them
the images shocked the feelings of world
leaders british prime minister john
major decided to take the issue to the
european community and convince the
first european partners and then
president bush to create humanitarian
corridors in iraq and so began what
would become operation provide comfort
aimed at getting refugees from the gulf
war to safety barely a year after the
conflict in the middle east and moving
elsewhere the united states decided
under heavy media pressure to intervene
in response to the humanitarian
emergency resulting from the somaly
civil war but in october 1993 everything
changed images of a usa soldier killed
and dragged through the streets of
mogadishu quickly went around the world
prompting president clinton to withdraw
troops from the territory john chateau
consistent secretary of state between
1993 and 1998 reveals how the media
first brought the us into somalia and
then out of the conflict according to a
so-called push and pull effect but the
ability of television to determine what
rises to the status of an international
crisis finds expressed confirmation in a
sentence authored by bill clinton on
july 17 1995 in response to the media
call for military intervention in bosnia
we have a war by cnn our position is
unsustainable it's killing the us
position of strength in the world well
even today we have come to the end i
thank you all for your attention and see
you in the next video ciao